encore une fois la capitale ukrainienne
a été réveillée très tôt par un bruit
tristement familier celui des frappes
russes d'où je suis
quelque chose volé au-dessus de nous
avec ce sifflement si particulier puis
on a entendu une explosion
on s'inquiète et on parle de
partir on aura peut-être pas
d'électricité ni de chauffage
ce lundi matin la Russie a attaqué des
infrastructures civiles dans plusieurs
régions du crâne dont celle de Kiev
80% de Kiev n'a plus d'eau courante
et certains quartiers de notre ville
sont sans électricité
coupure d'électricité plus à l'est aussi
à carquif les usagers du métro
patientent dans des rats malarrés le
métro s'est arrêté d'un coup alors j'ai
lu les infos et j'ai vu qu'il y avait eu
deux explosions dans des infrastructures
de cariffe privée les ukrainiens d’eau
et d'électricité en frappant leurs
infrastructures la Russie assume la
stratégie et se félicite de sa réussite
bonjour les messieurs
les forces armées russes sont
poursuivies leur frappe avec des armées
aériennes et maritimes à longue portée
et de haute précisions contre le
commandement militaire et les systèmes
énergétiques de l'Ukraine les frappes
ont atteint toutes leurs cibles selon le
chef de la police national ukrainienne
13 personnes ont été blessées dans les
attaques de lundi voilà et parallèlement
assez